from Riyadh as-Salihin, the final book
of Riyadh as-Salihin or second-to-last
book
based on the different nusqa.
And
the first narration, which is the
narration of an-Nawwas ibn Sam'an
radiyallahu anhu with respect to the
descriptions of the Dajjal, the
descriptions of what is referred to as
the Antichrist. And what are these
descriptions that the Prophet sallallahu
alayhi wasallam mentions?
We left off at
the Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
telling us
that the Dajjal will move across the
earth.
He will be in the earth how many days?
40 days. The first of those 40 days is
is equivalent to
a year, and the second
a month, the third
a week, and then the remaining 37 days
are regular days. Now, this is
literal.
How do we know it's literal? Because the
Prophet sallallahu alayhi wasallam
told us to do what
during this time?
To average the times for salah.
Right? To average the times for the
daily salah. If this was merely
figurative, meaning it just feels like
that, then we would only be obligated to
make five prayers during that first
year. Right? Five prayers during that
second year.
Or that second day, or which is
equivalent to a month. However, he told
us to what? To average and make the
prayers
every you know, few hours as it would
be
if if this this dilation of time had
not happened, okay?
The second thing is that the Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam described
that he will sweep across the Earth.
He will not leave a single village,
city, town, except that he will enter
it.
And he gave us a description of his
speed and swiftness through the land
that of a hard rain pushed by a
howling wind.
And that
he will come upon each town, each
village, each people, and he will call
them to pledge their allegiance to him,
to follow him, to adhere to him, to
receive his teachings, to embrace
his rules and laws and and so forth.
And so if a people believe in him and
accept him and follow him,
he will command the sky to rain and the
Earth to bring forth its vegetation.
And even the meat on the bones of their
livestock and the milk in its udders
will be overflowing.
And the exact opposite for those who
reject him.
And this gives us some hope because this
tells us that yes, there will be people
that will reject him. There will be
entire villages, entire cities, entire
towns where he will not be welcome.
And they will suffer for a time
because the opposite will happen for
them. However,
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
will provide for them during this
very perilous time.
And that he will come across a
a town or village or city that is, ,
barren
and abandoned and decrepit and he will,
, command the riches
of that town, whatever is buried in the
ground, whatever, all those treasures to
spring forth
and people will hence be,
,
seduced by his vanity.
[Silence]
And so, , al-gharat is a target that a
person would put up for himself if he's
practicing archery. The Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam says here
that he will encounter a young man
and this Dajjal will cut this young man
into two halves.
And he will cut him into two halves and
separate the two halves
the distance between an archer and his
targets.
Right?
30, 40, 50 yards, somewhere around
there.
And then,
he will call him back to life,
and the two halves will mend again, and
the young boy will
seemingly come back to life,
his face lit up smiling.
So, this tells us that there is extreme
technology here. What kind of
[Arabic recitation]
We don't know
all of this. Sometimes you'll find that
it's referred to as magic, sometimes
you'll find that some scholars refer to
it as technology. What is the difference
between magic and technology?
Very little.
Magic
that's mentioned in the Quran most
usually is is used using
al-shayatin to
make
illusions, right?
And technology, in this kind of
technology, is
has very little difference between it
and what is referred to as magic. It
will appear to be magic. It is some kind
of technology.
And now,
sometimes
a question that
many brothers have asked is
why would Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala give
him such abilities?
Well, the the first answer is that Allah
[Arabic recitation]
give him these abilities
he gives the prophets and
messengers abilities.
These are technologies. It's a
culmination of all of the discoveries of
humanity at that time.
Right?
Do we believe honestly that
we, the regular people, you and I, just
regular Joe, has access to all modern
technology today?
Do we have access to all modern
technology? Are we probably 20, maybe
more realistically 30 years behind
modern technology today? The technology
that you and I have access to.
for instance, AI.
Right? Your Grok and your ChatGPT and
your
Is this real AI? This is a child's toy.
It's just an entertainment device.
That's all it is. It just helps you do
your calendar and helps you write an
essay and helps you That's all it is.
It's not cutting edge, bleeding edge,
AI.
Right? These things are kept under lock
and key.
It's not shared with all of humanity.
And that goes for all fields of
science and technology. Whether that's
in the medical field, whether that's in
the
you know, field of AI, whether that's in
the field of military, with that whether
that's in the field of aircraft, whether
that's in the field of weapons, whether
that's in the field of
Right?
And this is normal. I mean, governments
invest billions and billions and
billions and billions of dollars
every single year into military. Where
do you think that money goes?
It doesn't go to buying boots and
shirts and t-shirts and and buying you
know,
rifles and pistols and stuff. That's not
where that money's going.
It's going to labs. It's going to
scientists. It's paying men and women
exorbitant amount of money to keep quiet
and keep their technologies under wraps.
Whatever this Dajjal is, he will have
access to these technologies. This is
not something that Allah necessarily
gave him specifically alone without
anyone else. This is he will have access
to modern technology of that time. If we
if you and I right now
were really shown modern technology,
right? Modern AI, modern aircraft, the
the truly cutting-edge
most modern aircraft on Earth today,
would we not call it magic?
Huh?
Yeah, we would. We'd call it magic.
The militaries and governments, they
have technologies that are beyond our
imagination at this point. we said,
20 30 years into the future.
you know, the internet. When did we get
the internet?
You guys remember around when?
Early '90s. Yeah. You know when the
internet was first invented and and used
by the military?
Yeah, in the '70s.
Yeah.
What about video call?
When was the first time we were able to
use video call, you think?
2000s? You know when the first video
calls were made?
1800s.
You know when the first faxes were sent?
1820s.
Shall I go on? Electric cars?
You know when the first electric cars
were really around? 1880s.
18, not 19. 18.
Okay, so we have little toys.
You know, our
fancy laptop that cost $3,000. This is
the cutting edge. This is the latest
technology.
Right? This is This is the Stone Age.
So, these things are kept under wraps.
The Dajjal will emerge. Yes, he will
have access to a lot of these things.
And this usually means that a lot of the
countries and governments and so forth
will consolidate behind the Dajjal and
give him access to these technologies.
You wanted to say something?
[Silence]
That's around today, right now.
Rain seeding?
Right?
Cloud seeding. yeah, cloud seeding.
Even the clouds themselves cloud seeding
is actually old technology. Now, we
actually make our own clouds.
Look it up.
There's actually giant mega
machine We're talking about the size of
a a small town machine that makes
clouds.
NASA owns the patent. It doesn't just
own a patent, it's actually existing.
There's video footage of it. Pumping out
clouds, and those clouds don't just look
clouds, they have rain in them and
they rain.
Right?
you know, etc. These are the kinds of
things that In our time, it's a lot
easier for us to conceptualize these
things. In the In the companions' times,
I mean, what else would they call it?
Right?
However, these are things that are
becoming more and more And this is just
what we know about. Cloud seeding,
you know, chemtrails,
nano nano dust.
All right? Nano dust, which is actually
looks fog. This is not a
conspiracy theory or anything. Nano dust
was developed over 36 years ago by NASA.
You will breathe it into your lungs. It
can be injected into the blood.
an entire town can be,
you know, flooded with this nano
dust. It's called nano dust. It runs off
of the electric it electricity in the
human body. And
it can
receive and transmit data,
information.
the person who has it in his
bloodstream can be made to hurt, hear
things that are not there, see things
that are not there.
Right?
These are just things that we have
access to now.
you know, they don't make the front page
of
the news, but these are things that were
around in the '90s. So, could you
imagine what's going on today?
I'm telling you that
you know, fax machines were around in
the 1800s and video calls were around in
the 1800s.
It blows your mind, right? It's It's
like
how could that be? Yes, it could be. I
mean, even in in Germany between
World War I and World War II, the public
had access to video calling.
And actually the video was resolute
enough that you could read the hands
on a watch on a wristwatch on the video.
You'd go and there were booths and you
would pay by the minute or pay by the
hour or, you know, however you pay and
you could have a video call with
someone, you know, on the other side of
Europe.
This was public access
in the early 1900s.
Right? So, these things
what we have access today
and and and say that for medicine, say
that for the medical field, say that for
engineering, say that for, right? All of
these things, which is why we stress so
much
that do not believe what you hear, do
not believe what you see, especially if
it comes off of a screen. Always take it
with a a grain of salt, right? Doesn't
mean everything is a lie,
but it also doesn't mean that everything
is true and verified. And what little
morsel of truth is found on the news or
on a on your on your feed on your phone
is
added many myths, truths, and
misdirections, and so forth.
So, this this is becoming a lot more
simpler to
conceive of these days. We we have a lot
of these things right now even. I mean,
we could do
many of the things that are in this
narration alone ourselves right now with
the technology that the public has
access to.
Right? There are some things that we
couldn't, but many of these things it's
very easy for us to understand in these
days.
another question that was asked was
what is the purpose of a Dajjal? Why
would Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala have a
Dajjal do this?
Why does a Dajjal emerge
for the ultimate goal and the ultimate
purpose of this world? What is the
purpose of this dunya?
So that Allah will
separate between good and evil.
Right? So that Allah will make good
better and evil will
become worse by their own devices so
that
the people of paradise will fill
paradise and enjoy the fruits of their
labor and and belief and so that those
who deserve the justice of Allah will
receive the justice of Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
And this is a fitna which comes near the
end of time. People will be subject to
this fitna and there are those who will
enter paradise because of this fitna and
others who will enter the the hellfire
because of this fitna.
Right?
I mean, we could say the same thing for
Iblis. Why does Allah Why did Allah
create Iblis?
Why did Allah
create, you know, the shayatin? Why
does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala allow
Iblis to whisper to Adam alayhis salaam?
That's the whole point of us being on
this dunya. It is
[Arabic recitation]
may yakhafu bil ghayb.
shay'in min as-sayd.
[Arabic recitation]
purpose of this dunya, our existence, in
order that we will have the choice
to obey Allah or to disobey Allah and to
exercise our free will and knowledge,
right?
And this is an incredible gift from
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala which will be
squandered by many.
We will finish this
be it in the light of Allah when I
come back starting tomorrow. I'm
going to be out for a couple of weeks.
I'm going to do some traveling
inshallah. I'll be back
in the second week of May. So, you will
have
Al-Akhdari and Al-Akh Assim with you
for all of the prayers, every single
salah. They will be here inshallah, one
of them to lead salah
including Zuhur, including Asr,
including Fajr. So, inshallah, I'll
see you all when we get back.